when seinfeld first started
none of us expected it to last
i was in charge of the music i turned
that mother out
jonathan wolfe is the man behind
seinfeld's iconic sound
but what even the most dedicated fans
may not realize is that the theme song
was actually different for every episode
i have no idea how many themes we did
for seinfeld i knew that each monologue
was going to be different because he
tells different jokes the timing the
length had to be adjustable in a way
that would it would still hold water and
still sound like the seinfeld theme so
each monologue had its own recording of
the seinfeld theme to match those
timings oh people in florida they drive
slow
and they sit low
right it all started with a phone call
from jerry hello
when jonathan first began to compose a
theme he knew he wanted to use unique
sounds that didn't drown out jerry's
voice
he ended up using his own fingers and
mouth as instruments
and i had his attention
it's like the declaration of
independence who's gonna read that
after that jonathan spent time watching
jerry on tv he noticed something
i watched his hbo special and noticed
that jerry has a lyrical delivery to his
jokes
and i put a clock on it
about 110
and that became the
tempo of the seinfeld theme the baseline
for seinfeld
so simple it can start and stop for his
jokes
hold for laughs
and in that way i could architect
each piece of music for each monologue
lego style
and that is how the seinfeld theme was
born
oh my god this drawer is filled with
fruit lobe in the end jonathan's music
almost didn't make it onto the show
jerry loved the music larry david loved
the music everybody on board
except the network the notes were
what is this music what is that
instrument could we not afford real
music it's distracting
it's annoying
but larry david wasn't having it larry
david the hero of this story
liked that it was annoying
said don't you dare
wolf you're done here get out
and i left and the music stayed in the
picture
[Music]
you